une séance importants sont le président
du département pierre bédier les
conseillers départementaux se sont
réunis ce matin versailles à l'ordre du
jour la dissolution de l'eau pied voit
l'un des plus gros bailleurs sociaux
d'ile-de-france avec cinquante mille
logements dont 17500 dans les yvelines
une décision imposée par la loi allure
sur l'urbanisme qui prévoit le
démantèlement de la structure
ce qu'il faut retenir dans cette affaire
c'est que rien ne changera pour les
locataires puisque ignorons à nouveau
quittancement mais ça sera le même
niveau donc il n'y a pas d'augmentation
de loyer et rien ne changera pour les
personnels sinon que les personnels du
siège déménageront mais pour le reste
les personnels de proximité resteront et
les personnels du siège durera pas des
sentiments au centre des débats
également le financement des travaux
préparatoires de l'opération tram 13
express la désormais ex tangentielle
ouest reliant le rer a de
saint-germain-en-laye au rrc de
saint-cyr-l'ecole coût total des travaux
à 6 millions d'euros
ces infrastructures de transports en
commun sont dans notre esprit
complémentaire de toutes les autres
infrastructures de transport pour à la
fois améliorer notre cadre de vie
pouvoir se déplacer est agréable ne plus
être pollué par les embouteillages et
tout aussi agréable donc c'est c'est
dans cette logique des mobilités
nouvelle que s'inscrit le département
enfin le conseil départemental des
yvelines a également voté une
approbation du soutien financier à
hauteur de 5 millions d'euros afin
d'aménager la colline des longs cours en
vue des jeux olympiques et paralympiques
2024 le site qui culmine à 3 131 mètres
d'altitude a été retenue pour accueillir
les compétitions de vtt hommes et femmes
donc oui nous espérons que paris 2024
soit une réalité
nous l'espérons vraiment de tout coeur
et nous prendrons notre part dans cet
effort dont je dois dire qu'il est
raisonnable se rendent pas des jeux
olympiques
avec des dépenses que la france hélas
n'est plus capable de supporter la
prochaine séance du conseil
départemental sera organisée le 25
novembre prochain